um what role does the government have to
accept in ruining people's Christmases
oh well
um this is just the most disappointing
news actually the fact that we've got
these strikes going on they're going on
over Christmas people are trying to see
their families you know we don't get
that much time uh to all come together
and so it's really really disappointing
I mean obviously this is
um you know between the unions and and
uh the paymasters we have actually
um accepted in full all of the
um recommendations from the from the
from the Independent bodies and you know
I I do understand I mean I think all of
us understand that inflation is high and
it's you know we've got this fight due
to you know obviously external factors
in the war in Ukraine but you can't
spend your way out of inflation what
we're trying to do is get that balance
and we've accepted all the
recommendations and we've urged
um you know people not to strike but uh
yeah it's very disappointing that border
force will be striking over Christmas we
can't get on a train we can't fly
there'll be problems on the roads
what are you going to do about it well
we are doing our best to to mitigate as
far as possible so in the case of Border
Force um we will have we've got 2 000
military personnel who are trained who
are going to try and mitigate or try and
help with some of those roles at the
border but you know we do expect there
will be disruption and just and delays
but they will do their best and they're
also helping with the Health Service as
well or if you see that said yesterday
um he would do what he needs to do in
order to keep people safe what did he
mean
to keep people safe in regards well I'm
guessing he was suggesting that he would
bring in emergency measures so that
emergency services couldn't go on strike
well we have got some emergency measures
which have been introduced to Parliament
and I think they're they're looking at
you know what we need to do there but
yes that has been mentioned and we will
he said he will put legislation in place
so I expect that that will continue to
be brought forward okay so emergency
workers should not be allowed to strike
well I don't know what the extent of the
the I mean some you know that some
people are are not allowed to strike I
mean you know there are some contracts
which you know say people can't strike I
mean there are I mean the military can't
go on strike for example
um and they're the people who obviously
um are helping us in in a last resort
but they is it fair that squadies who
earn significantly less than people who
are going on strike should be asked or
expected to fill in well I think we
should be extremely grateful for them
for doing that because I think also I
think they're they've accepted a pay uh
settlement which I think is is less and
lower than some of the others as well I
mean how much sympathy do you have for
people though like we've talked
previously about nurses using food banks
firemen are using food banks as well we
were told by their Union this week the
pay review bodies came up with their
figures but that was before inflation
was running at 11 yes and you know
inflation is affecting every single
person not just in this country actually
in many many other countries I mean the
obr obviously the most important thing
is you can't spend your way out of
inflation so try and navigate so that
you can bring inflation down if
inflation is high everybody feels poorer
and that's what we're trying to avoid to
to make that short as possible because
you can't just spend your way out of
that if we continue to do that then
we'll have inflation with us all for a
lot longer so it's really critical and
the obr I think saw inflation starting
to fall
um by you know sort of uh next year
um the early part of next year and all
the things we put in place you know the
energy relief scheme Etc I can't Heat
their homes that's why we've got the
energy relief bill in place that was 55
billion pounds 55 billion pounds worth
of support just for for heating so we
are trying our best to get that balance
of a general strike I mean there's only
one day throughout the rest of December
that there isn't a strike in this
country we are on the verge of a general
strike and coordinated action by unions
and we can just look at that as we're
chatting um coordinated action by unions
can bring down governments
um well I mean that has happened in
history uh for sure um and you're not
worried about that
you know you can only do what you can do
to try and control this you know you've
got two options haven't you you've
either got the option of trying to make
a fair and balanced approach because of
course you know if we if we accepted all
of the paid demands I think it's 28
billion pounds that taxpayers would have
to pay you know that's that's not
government money that's that's the other
taxpayers so you know what we're trying
to do is get this fair and balanced uh
approach now you know in terms of the
public sector I know teachers are
balloting at the moment you know that
five percent for an experienced teacher
which is on the bands by the way if you
move up the Bands then that can be more
than that and 8.9 for a um for a new
teacher so those are on the on the
starting salaries and we've raised the
starting salaries
yet it's not matching inflation
completely but inflation will go down
before the end of that Year's period if
we stick to our course and try to you
know take sensible measures as we
outlined in the budget this government's
on the precipice of a general strike
well I mean you know the reality is we
we have a number of people who are
striking and it's really disappointing
you know we have to pull together as a
country we've been through an awful lot
we've been through the pandemic we're
now supporting uh Ukraine in their war
against Russia these impacts these are
all things that are happening in every
country and they're not you know they're
not specific to our government at all
um you know all we can do is try to
react to those react to them in a fair
and balanced way we have accepted all of
the pay recommendations they are not at
inflation levels but they are you know
reasonable and they're highest in
teaching in the teachers pay rise is the
highest in 30 years that we're
recommending that we're agreeing
inflation is the highest in 40 years yes
it is but you can't spend your way out
of inflation this is a really simple
message if you continue to spend your
way out of inflation it'll last for
longer and it'll impact everybody for
longer and that is where you get into
these spirals you can't get into a
spiral we have to take a sensible
balanced approach we have to navigate
the country through this it's really
really disappointing that people are
striking and it's really disappointing
they're striking at Christmas you know
we've missed the last two or three
Christmases have been completely
disrupted due to the pandemic you know
people want to get together with their
families we don't get a lot of time off
this is a great time we all try and
catch up and everybody's plans are being
disrupted lots of us are interconnected
lots of us have you know our eldest is
in France you know lots of people have
um people abroad and you know rely on
um the transport public transport to get
to see them I know you're here to talk
about funding for universities and
colleges um today
um there is concern that primary schools
are struggling though also to pay their
energy bills when they need to keep
those classrooms wrong because of fears
over strep a well that's why on Monday
this week
um or Monday or Tuesday I think you had
Nick Gibbon and we put in place at 500
million just for short-term energy
efficiencies within our schools so every
school has got an allocation which
they'll get very quickly to to do things
like lagging insulation
um heating controls LED lighting things
that will help them keep their bills
down obviously they also have the energy
relief scheme and we had two billion
pounds extra this year and next year
four schools they haven't had that money
yet but they'll be getting that they'll
find out their exact uh proportion of
that that they'll get by the end of the
year and they'll get it in April so
there is help it is on the way
um and you know we are working very much
and if anybody is particularly
struggling then they should get in touch
with the Department because you know we
do have people who will come and help
you work through how you you know get
those efficiencies in place a couple of
very short questions if I may apparently
the Albanian Ambassador was speaking uh
yesterday to the House of Commons
committee one of them um saying that
Albanian children are being bullied in
their schools because of a campaign of
discrimination by the Home Secretary
will you speak to her about the language
that she used oh I I haven't seen that
but you know bullying in schools you
know we completely are against any
bullying in schools and you know that
that isn't acceptable for anybody I I
hadn't heard that report but I will look
back in the department and see if we've
had any reports of that but bullion is
you know is wrong anyway you know for
anybody for any uh whether it's the
where they come from or the color of
their skill or skin or whether they're a
girl or a boy it's completely
unacceptable okay um will you miss about
Hancock
yeah I mean I was his PPS for a while
um and I have worked with him in the
health department I mean you know by the
time I guess he goes he'll have done
about 14 years of of service so I guess
he's decided I think it was pretty clear
when he went off to the Jungle that he
was probably thinking of a a a different
career it doesn't look as though it was
completely his choice though doesn't it
would have been deselected anyway well I
don't think anyone forced him to go to
the Jungle I mean I think I think that
was his choice yeah I meant stepping
down
well you you know I think there's
I mean it was clear to me I think I said
at the time that that indicated to me
that he was perhaps looking to you know
take on a different career path um one
maybe more like yours I don't know I
keep your mitts off it's good to see you
as always thanks very much